[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hallo we're back hello took a little
break decided you know maybe grab a bite
- yeah grab a drink - get a meal inside
iasts that you're ready for the next
adventure
yeah so at first I was like let's do
your 10 hour playthrough and then I was
like but wait hold on we have it on
Nintendo switch and then tendo's new
portable console and then you're like
hey it actually surprisingly looks
pretty good yeah it looks all right
maybe you but I don't know if this is
like pre-rendered or anything but by now
yeah so this is my first time actually
seeing the switch version so we might
all be in for a surprise so we're gonna
play through the first hour just show
you what it looks like there's a
character creator yes we need to make a
cool character to kind of exist
alongside all of our favorites that
everyone likes and I'm pretty sure
that's new but I'll let chat debunk my
thoughts if I'm wrong you know I'm
getting a to live on twitch but network
error so hopefully it works on twitch
I'm sorry if it does if you're in the
twitch chat let us know if you see this
stream or not bring this audio up this
is very important story that's happening
hi cutscenes oh that's pretty good give
me that anime baby where I'm where my
weaves at she's kind of make a note in
my book what does that say yes lots of
people down in the streets reached
target point time to be my favorite
spider-man okay that's pretty cool yeah
they do a lot of first-person get them
stuff in this which is kind of
interesting
oh I mean that's part of the experience
it feels like we're sipping through the
streets with the air going by so we've
got character crater is new is evil
cause so like
explosion it's not tighten I can't
believe this
so our Tarantino again yeah that's okay
first time you would have saw that if
you didn't really sorry if you haven't
watched the actual anime and that was a
I assumed the first season most people
who are our end of this are probably
people who like the anime have probably
watched I hope but one can only go yeah
I know that after this it definitely
goes back to the beginning of my first
season okay
and also just so you guys know by the
way this game is so well I had to go
after that oh did see he's like her
agency is he's ready to go
oh let's go so hear me out I just say an
attack on Titan VR game is the next
logical step I think I feel like you
definitely throw up like whoa that's not
oh it's like she knows what did you
write house kicks rhinos kicks very
strong roundhouse kicks there are some
things I'm kind of noticing that like
they may have made some serious
sacrifices to make sure that this could
run it ass off this is gameplay yeah
sweet kicks
round two
I expected more like that's where all
the where all the materials are those
first time Bob we can is it a black
screen like can you hear us or anything
like that I know it's kind of pointless
to ask us in four years of the camp here
right now
hello Francisco how's it going I hope
you're having a wonderful Friday
everyone else to this wonderful double
stream day got some attack on Titan
going on right now we're going in
[Music]
didn't block themselves that time this
is some crazy stream like was a dream at
that you're doing uh it looks like it's
more alive than it was before
yeah with seeing that tube dude I don't
know why this looks terrible
the hands now so again that Network area
I have no idea why that is I head onto
YouTube if you're having problems
yeah does it run at 60fps it seems like
it's pretty solid so far framerate wise
boost I can say that
6 a.m. in Korea good morning
Oh who's that
[Applause]
it's too boy the reason I stopped
watching the anime really oh yeah oh
you're not into this so I loved the
first eight episodes of attack on Titan
so much because it set up this like
super bleak like dangerous like anyone
can tie you don't know what's gonna
happen kind of like atmosphere and then
they killed the main character in early
this show doesn't mess around and then
he comes back you're like that means
anyone can come back that whole
atmosphere that you spend a lot of time
setting up well kind of like it hard
check me out on it but I love the
concept of the show so much like it's
dudes with katana swords flying around
like Spider Man like that's super badass
I'm really into that maybe I actually
play this games made me kind of want to
go back and check it out again so I'm
like oh there's some kind of cool story
stuff that's happening here in their
budget
you look at all these eatin it's a real
dangerous time it's really important so
we've got the the wall so it's given us
a whole bunch of exposition here yeah
yeah so no he that's fair enough Daniel
you know nothing I'm not even an anime
the biggest poser you are Yahtzee Ronnie
Shuhei Saturday that trophy
I don't know honey I finished the first
season of second time but yeah at some
point I kind of like checked out a
little kind of watching the first couple
episodes of season two but but there it
doesn't crazy good yeah yeah towards the
end the first season like all the lots
of stuff returns holds Lisa fact I just
saw thank you for summing thank you
joining us here's the colossus type the
mean boys brush so you know what went
back for me yeah
I accidentally wicked something when I
first started watching the show and I
accidentally found out who the crosses
thing was like right away oh well it's
cool solve the mystery so I think this
is when we're getting introduced to the
air that actually happens kind of far in
oh really yeah there's a lot of like
they do the whole like training and
everything anything they build it up
pretty well yeah they're definitely
going more for that light
invest in your own yeah there's a lot of
cool like RPGs like that to break down
for me do you really want to alright you
won't see them do you know who it is now
that humanity literally couldn't win
without Aaron discovering his Titan
powered stood
I don't know evil Kaz I'm not gonna
argue any of that I'm gonna sit back
that's fine but if you think about it
Levi could have potentially killed one
of the stronger well maybe not one of
the stronger plants but you could have
you fought toe-to-toe with a stronger
Titans and the female Titan I'm not
gonna say who it is necessarily but yeah
I wouldn't be shocked if the manga does
go crazy places maybe she's read the
manga just kind of go right through it
John Wesley it's also on ps4 we were
actually gonna place a ps4 version but I
figured why not show it on scripts which
see what the difference is it didn't see
is it pretty similar for you or I think
it might run better here I haven't
gotten so there are parts on the ps4 and
my like 10 hours I've been playing where
like buildings will get knocked over and
you'll like the game will fall down to
like maybe 10 FPS for like a little
little bit I haven't gotten a chance to
get into like a super intense fight yet
on this one so I'm curious to do that
but it looks like they kind of sacrifice
a little bit of like the fidelity to
make it run better so we'll we'll see
revenge on that armored Titan depending
on just one guy like Levi I won't save
you may that's fair I'm just I'm just
trying to throw it out there that there
are some humans that have the skill like
Micasa can get I think Mikasa like Grant
having watch these into and I haven't
read more but Mikasa I feel I can get to
Levi's level at some point potentially
do not watch the live-action movies I
feel like that's a general thing for
most anime stay away from the
live-action
you know Death Note was awful Fullmetal
just watch the animes repeat him of the
Titans just do it yeah or Sasha where's
my potato girl she shows up she's here
doing things got like social links with
all the main characters too which is
kind of a weird thing
good old head but later Jon Wesley what
okay what if so much drafty down in my
chair I just made you watch a live
action please Ida
I'd do it but I wouldn't have a good
time I'll tell you that much oh this is
important we'll find out here after I so
I want to point something out this is
really dumb in the character creation
but I did the one done there so so
you're gonna run through this you know
what I made a female on the ps4 I'll
make a mail list i right so they give
you these these defaults to kind of look
through and kind of choose let's go I'll
show you okay
serene let's pick up persona 4
protagonist short pick our voice here
yep that sounds good we'll go with that
this one character customization in
progress the next stage continue you
wish to edit further select no I was
make changes later so it just takes you
back to picking the templates or the
voice so you have to say yes and then
what takes you the name you have to back
out and then you can actually do all the
proper customization whereas if you hit
yes again you would have you just do the
name and then you you know you hear but
yes so you get don't get your hair and
all the stuff let's let's give
yourselves some some cool cool hair here
like a mohawk I'm not sure they let you
that's good yes he can kind of kind of
mix it all up
what it so I'm pretty sure they're all
just haircuts from characters in the
game or in the in the anime but yes so
you just kind of go with you're sure he
looks good yeah what killing it keep his
eyes the way they are got eyebrows turn
up that thickness you can change your
your outline of your face if you'd
really like to to kind of get like a
different different to find [ __ ] like
I'd like you to be a little taller yeah
yeah hey hold on I think that's or do
you want to make a monstrosity can you
make a monstrosity
so you can't really make anything to
like gross or ugly or anything okay but
here will be really tall give me the
smallest head smallest head more
aerodynamic so this is important what's
a spinor torso go very strong yeah
you're burly very mostly but you know
like no legs
oh I can go smaller than that Wow we can
make a monstrosity and realize we're
going with arms no I think it's as high
as it goes okay okay but you know arm
days notice
it's motorized let's make ourselves look
kind of tired I think oh that's good
perfect yeah real sleepy and you can
change your your inner wear so you can
change like that bowtie you think you
think it's a bowtie guy what's the next
one mostly mostly bowtie oh where I want
to show off our pecs exactly we need
something that's kind of there's nothing
you got a little hoodie that's nice oh
nothing cuts very deep you know let's go
with the bowtie
and let's kind of make it more formal
kind of a tuxedo look that's good
killing it you can choose to wear your
jacket or not to wear your jacket we
don't use our legs we use our just our
arms just our equipment and our arms you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna go without the
jacket this time okay I think that's
that's a pretty good way to do it and it
does let you change the color of
everything else so you think I'm some
kind of electric bright something bright
something just obnoxious like a Titan
would see you good oh we need to get rid
of him now exactly
think Johnny Bravo comfort we did it we
need yellow hair then oh yeah or I'll go
back that's not good with this kind of
light green that's very good and what
are our pants gonna be something
ridiculous
now that blue kind of hurts my eyes a
bit yeah think you think pink again yeah
oh yeah it kind of matches the thing
right there some track yellow the
clashing color business how you do you
what do I know this street might decide
it for me oh shoot oh I'm still debating
buying this on switch or PS 4 sinds yes
okay that's fair you know well give him
like normal blue jean pants give them a
little bit of something normal he's I'm
Johnny Bravo head of hair color and
we've got some that might be as blonde
as we can get no oh there that's that's
good perfect hold on let's get some
thick rims some we got deed are some
goggles that Dee dark you're feeling
Fiona oh oh shoot never mind we're too
cool for school killing it we're in we
did it we did it guys we did it
let's make our belts let's make it let's
make it make it make it all kind of
stick together with that this is good oh
yeah this is good we're like a Secret
Service agent except we'd skip like all
right there we go oh yeah what are we
gonna name our self Tony
Johnny Bravo John I don't know if you
got like a copyright infringement go
funny then Tony Tony Tony Bravo bravo
Bravo Bravo bro here we go Volvo that's
not a copywritten thing brought Bravo
Bravo
even better okay more we did it
this is our boy all the character too
cool for school oh sure
yep we're going back oh my god
this is the most important part this is
we are gonna play as oh my goodness this
is you can't go too hard or can you is
are too cool and then bring it in for
school for boom this is our boy
our boy we are set let's get back into
the gameplay cuz I'm raring to fight
some cool cool Titans some real tall
people with our hands this will probably
really dumb name things you can do in
this game oh shoot I can't like it
actually up and down it I have to push
the button for it I've come to take out
yeah you've come for rations I'm a
hungry boy look I'm role-playing my
character right now and the one thing
that too-cool-for-school is about is
getting getting rations
he needs that that food I think that's
not actually what it looks like hardly
graphs compared to the ps4 they are
definitely not as they're not as
detailed I guess but I'm still kind of
impressed with how it's running like FPS
wise oh my God look at him good boy
I like this how do you realize he also
has like like Butler gloves on oh he's
so strong yeah we we definitely skipped
like that
what though but see look we got our
equipment we don't need please let me
let me use my my stuff let me go
let me there we go now we're moving like
I said I think though you will have to
see one other stuff loads in the most
important thing I think from I keep
saying it is the being able to have it
like go frame rate wise like hit a
playable clip and I feel like this is 60
at least right now I can't believe this
but I can't really show you what that
would look like without actually putting
it up to the camera so yeah yeah be kind
of yes Raphael we're against like day we
don't do that
not here we're all about the we're all
about the glamour muscles that I don't
all the time every day we we made it
some sweet sweet circles oh this is it
our first fight Yeah right they're very
very accurate I can't believe it can you
see yes you can't change the skin tone I
just I didn't check it out because I
didn't want to spend too much time on
creating a character it's in there
though
I can't believe this
yeah you're a badass you're right he's
doing this all with sunglass oh my god
training for the next ring but I'm still
I'm still here
we're not like Aaron we're not failures
no we're gonna be the best trained
against big Titans they have multiple
places to hit apparently evil Cass says
there's apparently a new mechanic in the
game where you can save canonically dead
characters from death is what I heard a
plane I need to uh I think I haven't
they haven't made a big deal about it if
I have would say that I forgot that you
got a I'm just like trying to fight it
like it's an actual thing and not pay
attention to what it seems pretty well
part of it too I feel like is if it does
play well in handheld like this is the
game I type of game I was playing it oh
heck yeah
as your park chorong did you imagine how
cool you'd be on the bus if you're
playing attack on titan two on your
switch what's this oh it's just a tech
on titan - he probably doesn't you
probably levels up I really hated him
for being so whiny in the beginning can
you tighten cocaine that might be a sama
thing that might pop up later I'm only
like maybe 50% of the way through the
story so I haven't unlocked anything
like that yet
but that is a big thing with this one I
know that you can actually play as a
Titan looks like oh my god did you
imagine what the Titan version of this
guy would look like the only thing he
keeps his his dumb haircut and his
sunglasses and it would be amazing
see
get your cats chops so you don't eat you
don't need to worry about your lower
body in this this universe because it's
well you would if you're many a time
they run out of gas
well they run out of gas definitely
that's it's a huge thing in this game
actually you just gotta you got to make
sure that you never are not without
guests you've got to always go and check
out the supply point oh shoot
who would who would too-cool-for-school
go for I feel like Sasha was my like
reaction she's about rations she's about
eating my ration like that's they could
steal rations together definitely won't
be Mikasa the unship a bull this will be
on ps4 as well that's what that mainly
plated I don't know yeah
it's on the switch playstation for the
Vita xbox one and Davina well that's why
wiki says likes the wiki let me double
check I still can't believe how this is
actually kind of like besides the
obvious not looking as good outwardly
like it it plays and runs really well
more versatile experience the season two
story of the anime but in a game
relationships with familiar characters
[Music]
nailed it turn for Smash Brothers you
imagine I I had a realization yesterday
after we did our feature for characters
that should be in the new smash game
because I'm still very much in the camp
that it's a new smash game okay Travis
touchdown like get him up in there
especially because we got the the new No
More Heroes game coming out on the
switch like yeah I'm I'm being as real
as it gets
looks fun only heard the anime but I've
never seen it if it looks good you're
probably actually like the anime - oh
yeah look red chips we're doing it
everyone's everyone's like oh this new
person they cut up those those wooden
boards very well lay out all the Game
Boy Color portwenn stéfano I don't know
we'll have to talk to our friends at
Nintendo and see what they can do
do you think this is a gateway to anime
nosh gaming I don't think this is as
much of a gateway to anime as there's
other stuff I would say that if you
never watched anime like one of the
first ones I recommend is one punch man
I feel like it's it's got good variety
for like you know it's got action it's
got comedy yeah and it's only 12
episodes was really digestible and then
my next I don't know maybe this is just
newer stuff that's come out but like I
feel like another one
cuz I'm basically going through the
steps I went through with my girlfriend
oh yeah recommending animes that she's
going through right and the next one was
here my hero Academy I still have to
watch that one and I really should cuz
everyone's told me how good it is all
the time the possibilities are endless
who's gonna become my best friend I'm so
tall I did say make a tall character you
did and we delivered I didn't know
everyone else is gonna be short
yeah that's the thing oh so the good
thing too is if you if you're not
comfortable with how you've made your
character you can actually customize
them at any time
oh you can like remake them whenever you
want so you're not locked in I'm not a
fan of it myself but it's there if you
ever want to switch it up but we could
actually add that if we see watch and
learn from the high flyers that's a good
way to do it
watch and learn she said nah come on oh
I guess watch your friends that's hope
you'll go read oh right Tokyo cool ghoul
re which is like after the facts if
anyone watches Tokyo cool for school
Tokyo ghoul the anime doesn't
necessarily follow I know that the
director took some liberties get back to
the barracks talk to your friends
knocks gaming says one punch man is in
there too but so is this
and it's actually a living proof of it
most people got into anime because of a
ot in the last five years I say a second
Titans probably you can easily say it's
probably one of the bigger ones Stefano
asked maybe maybe I I say it's not only
because I didn't rest it didn't resonate
with me as much like I watch for that
right yeah I don't know if I were to do
it I'd recommend like I'll be like oh go
with Cowboy Bebop or like watch Gurren
Lagann yeah like those those are like my
fear like flcl you can watch that in a
night it's still really good like those
are those the ones I go but I am a
little bit worried because it's not the
same studio doing it anymore that my
hero game what's a kid I really hope
it's not evil cos I'm interested to play
it I'm also interested to play the the
new one piece game that's more open
world oh yeah I'm so tall why are you
more I'm looking down at ya I please i'm
role playing a character in the attack
on titan universe so anything lying
around here yeah let's go to the
officers rations store and steal
something from them she's way into that
not as noted above she was into it
hey you over there come over come over
and talk to me for a while I'm I'm
pretty into how this is like holding up
do we look good yeah we do yeah he's
he's kind of kind of on the same same
level as us I guess standing says I wish
there's a portable version of the ps4
night know I don't mean to veto
technically can't you do like the mobile
play with like your yeah there's like a
stream thing you can do with it thank
you very much hard to say like there
hasn't been that much manga right like
that's the problem with like the enemy
coming out a couple years after like the
last season is that how far out is the
manga like they can't catch up to it's
almost like they have to be on the next
art yeah and then they can do the
previous art error in the mirror asks
does the game completely open world or
is there limitation so it's you can walk
around in the towns and then you set out
on missions that are in like dynasty
Warriors style like big open areas I
wouldn't say it's like open-world though
back to some Tokyo ghoul knowledge Brian
ik says Tokyo ghoul first season skipped
a lot of stuff route a the second season
is the anime original I thought the
second season they they kind of tweaked
some of the stuff towards the end like
how things worked out but you sound like
you might be a little bit more
knowledgeable about Tokyo ghoul than I
am and he says that : Rhee is the direct
sequel to the manga so manga so it'll be
interesting to see how they do the anime
I feel bad that I'm kind of like
skipping through some of this text we
got to get back into point we're
fighting talking unless it's with Sasha
then maybe there you go yeah that's the
most important one look at how tiny his
legs are no totally getting rid of that
yikes although you might know how far
you are okay yeah this is a good good
call I'm not super I think I might give
it another shot at some point just to
just say that I did well I'm gonna watch
that first I actually have like a
process of a me that I'm watching
through right now is I just finished up
the danganronpa ones I'm gonna hit up my
hero at some point
sorry I just snickered that your name -
cools like right above that's pretty
good that's really good actually
yeah no one ever calls me about my full
name though I know they don't do that
yeah anyone got news on the one punch my
season to release don't no idea I don't
think there's a good date oh here we go
now we get to get back out and start
serving sometimes I don't even know if
that that one was true or not but what
side spoil or attempt spoils or anything
like that
I'll go take a nap you like to eat a nap
I got it okay that's my character he
actually sleeps with his sunglasses
still on am I really seeing game lag
when going to dash towards a Titan for
an attack well we haven't actually dash
towards a real Titan so the game when we
were doing stuff earlier there's like a
stylistic thing where it it slows down
when you like latch on and are about to
go in to kind of like make the impact
seem much more intense so I don't know
if it's like a frame drop as much as a
static choice visceral that's actually
kind of like the proper use of the word
visceral so like I might be like down
with that because that's there's
definitely a word the look at this group
of people I can see the Knights of
Cydonia it's a interesting song bite was
amused not gaming thinks that attack
time season 3 will most likely drop this
one but I don't know about that wouldn't
it start in April cuz like we're in the
process of finishing a season of like
just anime in general I think that if
it's gonna start it would start like in
April or after April like the next three
months out this is when we all learn to
work as a team got no gas or blades left
two cools got the answer we're gonna
build a we're gonna I want to go we're
gonna refuel hard look ok when the chips
are down who are you gonna count on too
cool for school
he's here to make it work you wanna go
take a nap we'll see this is the thing
it's all situational I propose we let to
cool here you'll have to call me captain
one more and add loads and I'm getting
rid of you for good he's looking down on
everyone literally he's like it's really
noticeable when you go up to talk to
people because of the fact that I yeah
this is when when you have no gas this
is what it looks like this is where we
got screwed skipping like yeah yeah
build the tower those are some pretty
pretty choice jams
yikes
the buttons are kind of different oh the
babies do I hope so we come out of
nowhere no one expects us the the RKO of
anime characters cool we're all stocked
up tell me where he goes so I can go set
up base
let's put this one over here do it you
know a little bit of variance and where
we're allowed to be this uh playing this
game and like just like the mobility
that's going on make me wanna play
spider-man yeah I think about spider-man
2 all the time just think about the new
spider-man coming up all the time it's
very exciting I would like to play yeah
I don't worry Braden Miller I'm gonna
get rid of that guy sounds like he said
none of the spoilers you said are true
it's kind of lame to kind of make people
out like that regardless but thank you
for update that makes me dead last
but where to Cooper's too cool is never
dead last
he's just biding his time look at that
you can call your teammates that's
pretty cool so you call in like just
kind of clue do they need to see the map
right now right Maps only a suggestion
yeah it's not so this use a lot of the
UI on this don't want a one-punch Fant
game where you sitting here in advance
of the rain from here
would be really cool I mean you could
technically argue they could be all they
probably won't do this you're my hero
could be that but my hero to you I like
the concept of having an anime game
based around an anime but then having
you create a character that exists in
the world with them cuz then you can
kind of be a part of the thing that you
want to worry about messing it up yeah
okay 200 we'll have to see
basically they said they hope that uh
spider-man ps4 is good they partly shown
anything
I mean they've shown it like at least
gameplay last year I would expect there
to be more this year release there is no
release date yet right
whoa that was they this it's gotta be I
don't think there's a release date for
yet though it's gotta be coming up
though like you think III they'll
probably talk about it at e3 I don't
know if if we'll get it by then maybe
it'll be like end of the year I'd like
to see it by the end of the year I think
it's just later for mm oh wait
apparently the rumors are yeah later
this year but want to see here's hoping
we will see my godoh pain says they
don't think that you can shift the other
time this one also saying that they
think that you can I don't know we're
not we haven't gotten that far into the
game but I wouldn't I would imagine that
if you're playing your character the
entire time which they'd have to lug
you'd have to be able to do that because
let's be real here outside of like a few
people like I had mentioned earlier like
Levi or possibly Mikasa like most people
can't compete with the Titans you know
if you can't turn into a Titan we got
some problems that's for sure
or like a moment where like you take
control of one of the other characters
or something during a story but nosh
gaming asking can you play makers of
attack on Titan like Aaron in the
offline mode so there's a mode called
another mode button on single-player of
our range yeah
so I'll get that later
I don't have it on okay so you unlock
characters by playing through the story
and then you can play as them in there
so I guess that maybe we'll be able to
check it out how much time you have
so don't exactly remember when so many
worst cases I could be like plugging
that ps4 just more tickets to me take us
to the that might be interesting thing
to do that actually just to get
comparison to change the title oh that's
right you just do like a bonus thing it
kind of kind of tossed it in not make it
too much of a focus hit up this supply
area really quick to cool and Co
training well you can play this Titan
shifters in the second mode your COC is
my shifter well dang I wanted to see
this guy turn into a Titan real bad be
very stronger than because they even in
this game shouldn't he always be
stronger than her I feel like he's a
just a real strong strong person isn't
he like the strongest well again having
to watch season two but in season 1 he's
definitely for sure like the strongest
like like human combat guy that I've
seen but maybe that was because Mikasa
was fighting with emotions don't do that
please show us the ps4 version as well
clicking the piecework please alright I
can change the title later that's fine
but we do only have about 15 to 20
minutes left so let me see if I can make
let me see if I can delay me showing up
to that he's he's putting off his
meetings just so he can show you guys
the game on the ps4 favorite channels
GameSpot I'm glad that you you like it
here try to make a good time for for
everyone to hang out and enjoy it
touchpad controls I think it just brings
up the map
but nothing to to bigger important
trains finish go home and give
yourselves a break a lot of people want
to see that are you done with this
mission yeah I just have to put one hour
of attack on Titan game we start on
switch then switch to ps4 maybe the the
switch we were talking about was
actually the switching between consoles
and not switch itself why maybe the real
friend we made along the way was just
the switches all right
is this the end I guess we'll get to the
book part of that you say and then we'll
make the switch I'm gonna miss old
too-cool-for-school got that s rank on
the mission
so that's rank so s rank friendships
leveled up everyone knows us better
we're all hanging out so I don't know if
I'll be able to show like late-game
stuff but I can show you guys 10 hours
in so that's as far as I've gotten
what'd you do what'd happen terrible I
just realized that I tried to retweeting
a tweet and then I'm like yo we tweet
switch link that doesn't work right now
oh yeah so you want to do the switch
yeah we can we just all right I'm gonna
go for camera yeah so you just need to
take that hutch HDMI did we unplug any
of that other stuff or did you keep it
plugged in so that was switch the switch
version of Nintendo switch version
rather of attack on Titan to like the
first 45 minutes or so and then now
we're gonna give you a taste of the ps4
version because so many people are
asking we'll play that other mode as
well as maybe a story mission don't know
mainly to show off the other mode and
gameplay because please don't forget
showing gameplay with main characters
start with Levi he's super fast and fun
to play sure we can do some of that
right now hopefully or shortly that is
the goal at least thank you everyone for
tuning in we appreciate it we go live
every day at 11 a.m. so come tune in for
that let's see our PlayStation is
booting up what's up John Wesley rip
audio I killed the gameplay I'll be back
it'll be back in a second once we
actually get into the game because
there's no reason for me to keep that on
make sure it thinks it was too hot to
keep my sweater on in this room it's a
little it's very very warm in here it's
like a sauna have you unlocked the
shifters besides Aaron in another mode
oh I don't know if you guys see one let
me know one I know some are but it just
depends if you can actually do it in the
thing oh look who's that fighting who I
can't believe all these people fighting
all these things all right here we go
way back in it all right
also we want to go into another mode
another most first okay I don't know if
Ryan would oh man people getting eaten
it's wild out here didn't show it what
you don't want to go the full way you
know show that should we skip this yeah
yeah yeah we don't miss monster hunter
came home late I'm glad that you're here
oh you gotta close that I got my
character here she's looking looking
real good you're all about the eye patch
oh yeah keep going keep going keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going
we got oh wait we were told to play as
Levi got him there who else we got those
or anyone that might I'm looking might
be more back left - one more
nope keep going wait it was at the end
now I keep going so the there's more off
over here OOP this is just the beginning
again okay going to the right there
might have been after Sasha who's that
no you don't have any okay
well then I guess we're gonna do Levi
that we're doing Levi goodbye its head
Toby's Tiny's he's here he's ready
offline I guess because I don't think
anyone else is playing but yeah what are
we gonna call this other mode and
another mode maybe now that ball do I
like it alright get your outfit can I
don't think I can choose my outfit I
don't know character editor oh yeah yeah
what's what's the most cannon outfit
what's the most important anyway I go
that way with the Cape with the Cape
hundred percent we can change the colors
on everything to shoot odd flippin get
it going
it's not candid anymore that's okay this
is my OC leave Oh a little bit salty
right now because of the knock because
non-canon alright yeah I need to go on a
mission now I need to go cut some cut
some things up it's been a while uh take
back the bass let's do it
all right ride that horse to the loading
screen we're doing it man riding the
horse where we're going we're going in
fun fact not Inaba was named by E se
llaman cuz her hair looks like a banana
stache sure dang that's it's a hot fact
I'm into it alright alright we got
horses oh it actually has my special
weapons and everything right we had a
hot seat so you get a horse later on in
the game which helps with the down time
as they do in the anime yeah I'm gonna
go help this boy out before we head over
to our actual objective you okay yes hi
Joe Levi teacher
yes he's gotta go oh you can ignore
where is he he's here somewhere
Oh sneak attack yeah get those sneak
attacks oh this is this is where it is
oh yeah this is when when like that
scream I shouldn't have said to play the
first Dow we should have been just
killing these things the whole time yeah
it's kind of weird that we we did all
that and we didn't even actually get the
point where we fought a Titan properly
but look how long your swords are this
is great I like the sword a lot actually
it's it's kind of the thing that's
that's making me get the most excited
about this game so they're so big are
you just like overpowered or like it's
just normal actually kind of possible oh
look at that guy these are the the Bashu
large abnormals yeah yeah he ain't
messing around oh maybe I can do the
thing
let's thing Oh get up do it right in
this junk here you go
so you can you can do some counters
which are kind of nice like I'm actually
really happy that worked out because it
looks pretty easy I bet you could do it
again probably probably maybe
just setting you up for failure
really that quickly hey I told you Levi
he's like one of the like his one of the
most like badass
yeah humans in this world you don't mess
with him yeah he's in New York so you
just walk up to the windscreen yeah oh
that boys real angry too many I never
get a chance you only got a B I went too
quick you think so I was probably didn't
go and save other people and I didn't
kill enough stuff on my way yeah that's
kind of good
nice thethe is thethis next time you can
help us heck yeah jump in on the on the
next race all right now it'll you so the
way that these scouting missions work is
you kind of like go mission a mission a
mission and then you eventually bring it
back to base and that's when you finish
it so we can keep going with it unless
you guys wanted to see like the story a
little bit all right well let's chat
decide you just you just do this for now
yeah and then we can maybe
oh my character is here that's real
weird just part of the team then another
thing too is you can craft new weapons
and stuff oh you get all these these
different blades this duster for some
reason I clean them off oh that's kind
of cool it's just like a spec barbell
Wow yeah I'm gonna do it
so that'll that actually affects like
your reach and everything else you can
get some different like holsters
scabbards I guess if you want to be cool
about it but uh and then you can also
get different mechanisms for linking it
all together so there's there's a quick
stuff going on can level it up upgrade
it okay I'm gonna stick with what I got
because really into it grow the next
area
well well everyone tells us we want to
see more story I'll just go on to the
next one
okay it's the easiest way to do it
remind me to change the title later or
you can just change it to write a new
story these missions are gonna be too
low level
okay well we'll wrap this one up and
then I'll just go to the story then
fair yeah yeah it's kind of weird that
the horses don't run away well he said
that apparently Titans don't eat horses
unless it's the beasts title in which
case he hates horses and Tanja's so you
know there's that why you gotta eat all
the horses oh I see some counters does
it really only work against those like
really aggressive
thanks so you can make any Titan angry
at you so it does that yeah it just
makes it easier to kind of focus in on
them everybody changed the title now I'm
just gonna change it now because someone
already was like I didn't know the
switch had a triangle but it does it
surprise
so the other interesting thing about
this game is the like ragdoll physics
that we use we've got some like weird
gta4 like reactionary physics going on
and it makes for some kind of really
funny stuff going on down there I have
now changed it to attack on Titan to one
hour of live quick gameplay
can't wait for the vaad when people are
like this is more than an hour that's
all so hey Gary I noticed that my my
character is actually running around in
the field - yeah they're probably part
of the squad right I was soon yeah like
that's pretty cool I didn't realize the
day it's a more personal experience I
feel like I've left a mark oh no what
there's a real big boy yeah give me that
counter oh boy oh boy I have to actually
run no I just managed to escape but I
didn't get the counter quite did it too
early so they're real hard to pull off
just together like time it exactly right
that's fine but whoever managed to get
that one I'll still try to kind of keep
my eye out for more opportunities but
this guy's doesn't skip like they know
clearly got a good balanced regiment is
a very very mostly boy so you actually
can't chop limbs off and whatnot Oh too
soon right yeah yeah oh like this you do
like cool team attacks yeah yeah that's
much quicker than that usually goes yeah
okay on the story yeah I'm into it okay
we'll do it what's right on the first
one with with grab it it's a pretty good
looking game considering like it's
definitely cut off all his limbs up too
late sorry it's fine we'll do something
weekly cut his arms off I mean you get a
new a new perk that's a good time
changes okay alright so we're gonna do
some story we're about you're about 10
hours in like 10 hours in yeah yeah yeah
but yeah we are checking out attack on
Titan 2 comes out next week March 20th
we are currently playing on the ps4 we
we checked out the first 45 minutes or
so of this stream on the Nintendo switch
so you get two flavors of it I haven't
noticed anything like substantially
different yeah it's actually I mean it's
hard for me to compare because we didn't
actually fight a Titan yeah yeah I still
think like just going off of like
playing it on the ps4 then playing it
again on the switch them pretty
impressed with the switch like fer for
being like a smaller less powerful
console it still looks pretty good and
plays really well this story right yeah
so we're back in the main town we're
very character my character that I made
we're gonna run around and talk to some
people and then hopefully get a quiet
area mission our next mission yeah yeah
how's the Social Link system 10 hours in
um you get little like events where you
kind of like talk to people when you
level it up and you get special perks
that you can use to assign to your
character from each level up you get
it's it's not big but it's it's pretty
good
yes sir take me there
ah cutscenes generic gaming I guess one
of the biggest changes would be you have
your own character in this game versus
my curiosity or maybe I don't want he's
like your Levi's boss essentially okay
and he has been out in the field so he's
more like a tactical genius kind of
thing from what I know some curious how
strong he actually is though like as an
actual Lego fighter fighting as long as
the 20 hours seems about right because
I'm like 50% through I say I'm really
looking forward to this being like a
really important like part in the actual
story and we're like oh no maybe we
shouldn't have done this it might be
part of the first season anime depending
on what fight you're about to embark on
yeah well see everyone seems very uneasy
mechanic wise I can't say too much an
area gaming because I haven't played
both myself from what I understand they
changed the the buttons around a bit to
make more sense and kind of play a
little better it feels good I like doing
it
so mean oh yeah these are the only
people that left to stay to fight on his
life survey or his little oh yeah here
we are
I think this is what I think it is
they're gonna get like these all look
like main characters they're gonna go
out of the wall oh I think it is but I
don't know we'll see could be wrong cuz
our sir group what's my god
I know counting on you out there look at
his mouth just keep talking well you
look okay he's really excited to be here
yeah I'm kind of curious about Owens
history as well I haven't read that long
ago so I don't know everyone is the
commander and planner and he's okay in a
fight but better at tactics yeah I could
see that evil cause you need to have
that you need to have that tactical
genius
why is he sweeping because he's a bad
boy and has to like I wouldn't tell that
boy to sweep anything I know what he's
capable of knocking he says he never
really fights after season two and even
in one and two he's just good at leading
his soldiers in gambling he's a beast
though and badass especially in season
two I gotta watch season two I got to
get past the boring part to get to the
good part too big for his boots Wayne
Wayne be careful he's got too cute for
schools haircut why is he stealing our
original characters we had more like
sort of a hair part looks kind of
similar it's kind of hard to tell
also on a different console boy wait
this is ten hours in this wasn't even
halfway through the first game yeah
right look you've already known yes
Harry went through trial got lashed okay
we're about to actually do a mission
right let's go to make sure we'll find
out well that's all I have time for
because I'm already late okay well we'll
go through this as quick as we can it's
all right
do do they understand this is this is
anime this is you can't rush anime if
you haven't played it even seen season
two I strongly recommend you don't put a
certain load that's fine yes sir yes sir
I'm very sure that I want to go you're
not afraid hello empty mistake
welcome says they're new welcome I'm
pretty sure you vote Kasim listen I'm
mistaken I would think this is like
right when they're about to go out of
the walls potentially run into a female
you know Titan maybe but I could be
wrong I don't know exactly where is that
I'm just basing it off of what I think
is right
what are you why are you reading about I
was loading I can't it's like this is
what I've been waiting for this whole
time I wanted to learn about the Scout
regiment horses and that finally bit the
horse right now there's only five hours
of the game if only there was Sonic
Heroes music playing questions lovely
boys thank you the funny thing is
hearing my own voice I hate it yeah no
that's Miller I feel like that here's
their own voice
it's never a fun thing to listen to
yourself I was before though and it was
a heck of a time like this I'm sure this
sounds good I don't need to listen to it
at all yeah I know you just like play
the music yeah yeah the extra wall you
haven't even given me my cool poncho yet
they just shroud you and miss you
they don't know so they do a weird thing
where they they don't acknowledge the
gender of your character at all though
constantly call you the same thing and
it's our guy it's too hard to like yeah
I can understand the need to kind of
like bring it all down to kind of like
make it easier to to put everything
together but it's also probably why they
do the first-person where the hell are
you that's I don't show me a show many
things if I am it's always a
first-person yeah I'm pretty sure this
is everyone's too happy right now
yeah bad things are gonna happen so I
haven't heard the attack on Titan
which is the biggest injustice we should
probably save it for when we're over
fight yeah I feel like that's the
maximum most often usage of it okay
that's fair oh shoot here we are
oh this is a no were you venture out
what surprised there's not what I
thought was gonna happen
chapter 3 episode 1 beside me yeah
beyond the walls so maybe it's preparing
to go beyond the walls yeah I thought it
was gonna be why on earth are they
making me use my horse for the inside
the town part of the one wall that fell
so you wrote it into this area I would
assume this is the first one to follow
the Maria Rosa it sounds familiar yes to
say someone someone definitely knows
better than the neither lost
what happens when they send out the
distress smoke they supposed to go help
them
yeah and it gives you like items for
doing it
go get them they're all for doing it
you're making the things happen oh hello
get out I got you with one hand it's
okay I'm gonna cut his fingers off there
goes his index and middle finger he
won't be flipping anyone off anytime
soon sucks man you're not as strong as
people hey no hey here we go combination
attack I want an efficient one in his
head to fly off Oh never been real good
actually
get out of here are the horses still
pain in the ass control they're not
difficult but they're not not like
they're not fun I'm much rather than you
like zipping around got it so now he
says this is beyond the walls walls
Marie wall Maria was taken all the time
so I was right I think if I said what
does scope you look through do is that
in you it allows them to do sneak
attacks I think right yeah so if you if
you Scout something long enough you'll
be able to do it but also they can sense
when you're looking at them and if you
pull one off right you get 1039 damage
but this guy's a burly boy he's very
very muscly
why do you chop his leg off yeah yeah
it's the interesting thing about these
swords and I'm using in particular is
the fact that because they've got such a
high reach they can actually kick things
to what you're hitting this really quick
so I don't think he's gonna be going
anywhere
look at him trying to stand up with one
leg like a goofball what a dummy
we got an eye don't you get you an item
for helping out your pals
you got 56 seconds to eliminate the
table for the follow-up squad sneak
attack engage whoo Wham
too far these guys are too too good to
get one shot what see watch out for that
guy I always hated the waddles yeah
there's always as well terrified oh my
swords bro all right now what now -
you're next
you gotta go only six more seconds I
should probably fighting these guys then
Oh
we thank he's very angry trip them up
I'm just gonna fall down not be able to
scoop it I mean when you're like kind of
like dark ride he's a grown on you or
yeah yeah chop them fingers off then
there goes it stop - oh you failed shoot
I didn't get him fast enough so they're
also real weird fail states sometimes -
like they kind of they're really good
with checkpoints at least okay I don't
think they're doing them I live in their
best life so like you didn't actually
fail that's that's pretty good was it
like a side version I think it might be
just like I make it less difficult
coming up kind of thing don't forget you
have items like Flash bombs etc yeah I
haven't had to think about using one
night yeah I also saved like my fire
bombs and stuff the one we've got like a
big reviews so I got both of his legs
cut off I can actually capture this
Monster Hunter dude there's a lot of
moss 400 going on in this game and maybe
that's why I'm kind of like digging it
but Oh shoots not I wanted to do what a
capture them there then you know
sometimes you just got to shoot in that
out and see what happens
[Music]
I already miss Levi yeah is a better
singer is there like a is there one
where you like both chola guys little
but where you top off where you chop off
the legs together oh look at how many
guys are attacking this one guy so
that's the thing they don't attack
unless you tell them to so they'll just
sit there and spin around like that it's
like we're like a bunch of like bees
swarming some guys and they just just
don't go in boss tell us what's dude I
can't I can't believe this what where do
I go I'm gonna go save this guy actually
where he gets I can actually get over to
yep didn't hear Oh Tommy you gotta there
otherwise he's gonna better out of here
one more for the win yes there there we
go
superior elimination keep a closer eye
by gas canisters ah Sh
everyone attack at the same time well
they're all just gonna spin around all
on my pal here we go do this that one
item get to the windmill area build a
thing really create some surprise I know
what's gonna happen over here did you
restock though so you get a restock
every time you build something okay so
you guys automatically every stop
doesn't a hit this one up over here so I
can actually get like another restock
some kind of a kind of sexy I'm here
Oh provide support I realized what's
happening now there's all the ability
and equipment crafting and upgrade
stolen yeah yeah dan those Titans must
be lifting buildings to be buffed
we've gone right there I empty mistake
happens all the time they run out around
on the fields a lot so that's why they
don't they don't really ever skip like
their everyday is like taking your title
what would have loved to have seen this
far on the switch version yeah we just
got the switch version I think today so
Ben had had the misfortune like a couple
days ago so that's why he was able to
get a little bit of a head start I just
figured it was worth showing the switch
version and especially now that more
people have switches and maybe they
would be interested in this game on the
switch whereas you seen this game before
on PlayStation Xbox the toys
all right build that base you're gonna
do a manly operator because it's in the
middle oh so you could have mounted that
part oh yeah I could have went inside
it's really nice because you can
actually one-shot most with it sup guys
in here let's hit this point real quick
yeah sure
go take your time she got a horse
well amputation that's so violent yeah
welcome to attack on Titan yeah and also
you should watch what they eat people
yes that's a thing if anything that's
the most horrific thing if you've never
seen that happen there you go we made it
everyone's okay whoops I was supposed to
probably supposed to play this sooner I
totally forgot
I'm single we go help that's that sad
person
this is what I was supposed to play
ready yeah it's so why would they not
have it in the game too much why because
it gets all this is this is I feel like
that's not supposed to be
I still counted that failed attack
what's that you failed one yeah so it's
those worth it that was good
I was into it genetic game said I can
I've definitely sold on this game now
third what'd you do in the multiplayer
or share campaign or just shared
campaign I think it's just doing the
Scout mission I don't know now his legs
been oh wait what am i didn't saw the
follow-up squad arrives I'll have to
join forces to swim do I'm doing it I'm
doing the thing haha
off the phone a plus production guy
you're damn right I could have did it
off the computer to you if I feel like
it would have been really loud but it
gives it more character if if you do it
this way you know
it's got both of the legs at one time
that's hitting the money two-for-one
special is what I like to call it buy
one get one free the light special yep
like it oh yeah you don't need your legs
anymore just like a garden gnome capture
this boy yeah I think these ones are
actually just steps s just capture him
because he's small I don't have to cut
him up at all let's try to go anytime
all right it's too slow a group of Aaron
there's multiple Aaron I can't believe
this you like the opening of season two
better than the first it's an anime
anthem white
I can't we should just do a feature
article top 10 anime openings oh I've
been I've got so many man I've been
trying to like get them to do top 10
anime fights for the season top 10 anime
portrayals yep
exactly but they're all over YouTube
though your gives I watch them every now
and then news
kiss there's some anime that I wasn't
watching you know what what does
GameSpot's take on this what is waiting
for GameSpot to weigh in on the top 10
anime betrayals of all time heaven
having some some interesting times here
and Kelleen actually leave these guys
alone because I realize that our
objectives over here I keep thinking you
finished the mission and you didn't yep
oh there's large abnormal go on for a
bit it's closing in on the group of
errands no not my group of errands just
resupply oh I have to help another one
of these
funny thing is I watched the first
couple episodes and if I remember it I
[Music]
hate most of the HUD elements why would
they show damaged numbers in this when
you attack
I like it Time Attack numbers for some
reason it gives you a good tangible feel
of like how your character is
progressing I guess because they try to
bill it as like a light a light RPG
that's a pretty good take on it I'm in
poor angle
oh no Mikasa way she's one of our
strongest try she should go
sure take care of something
oh god eysan two actually had me so
angry no I really wanted bleach to end
after the eysan are the the Arrancar are
but you know anime and manga money money
is a big thing oh you're quick that's
right
no yes Petra got it we're good
where's a large abnormal over there
it'll cost trouble for the main force if
we don't do something I've got a plan
hold on yeah yeah yeah
get down oh yeah I forgot they can if I
let them get close something just gonna
eat me out of it like how does it feel
to get in artillery bride
one shot that guy where'd you go right
in the button
think he's weak so I can actually Ichigo
that's just how it goes when you grapple
it does it the game itself I slow down
yeah I think I think it's just a
stylistic thing we are currently playing
on the ps4 we switched off of the switch
because people wanted to see later into
the game so the first 45 minutes or so
we played on the Nintendo switch and now
we've switch to the ps4 whoa how can
that one did someone point in so the way
that you fight these is you you're
supposed to attack their weak points are
like green wallowing thing but their
parts and then from there they'll get
knocked down and they'll take all the
damage that's so you kind of like see I
think it's goodies changing between
having to jump out here a bit that was
the bait
right into my trap I've got you now
calling one of these there you go that's
it yeah it's a good way to do it I think
I might have actually finished the
mission yeah we did it we did it okay
solely because of your sad because if we
were hoorah all right that's fair
in Freight says I can't wait until it's
out on the switch this upcoming week
yeah I'll be out about four days I think
the I think the switch version is pretty
good from what I plays just on the
stream today what happened on your first
mission I don't want to talk about it
how do you so you lock on with r1 and
then you press triangle to latch on and
then you can then angle yourself with
the stick and then you let go of the
stick and you'll car start to reel in
and then you time your press of triangle
again with one you want to slash that's
way more complicated yes I just wanted
to like I want to let you know I got you
there you go but that's the the process
back to your position he looks like
you'd rather be literally anywhere else
than here right now a mission outside
the walls oh it can't be I can't believe
this
why would we go outside of our
comfortable walls the outside your grip
route guard yeah gotta go around the
outside no look at these cool Titans
that I got collected all these cool
little boys drew him inside of my book
did that pretty good here yeah I think I
think we've done it alright that was a
fun little bonus stream as I like to
call them sometimes so yeah if you want
to watch and you missed the Nintendo
switch portion on the stream you just
DVR back to the first like 30 45 minutes
we do that and then this lasts you know
20 30 about 30 40 minutes has been on
the ps4 10 hours into the game we did a
little bit of that another mode there's
a little too easy
yeah that's a attack on Titan 2 comes
out on March 20th which is next week on
Tuesday you want to check it out go and
do so for yourself I think I reviews in
QA so hopefully get that out shortly
maybe next couple days or so but stay
tuned for that and until next week when
we have a lot more streams come back at
11 a.m. and Oh quick question what do
you do with your capture Titans research
new things with them yeah thanks man any
last thoughts words tackle Titan be cool
stay in school